aujourd'hui le sucre est tellement
répandue dans notre société que si on
retirait des étagères d'un supermarché
tous les produits qui en contiennent
il n'en resterait que 20% avec l'arrivée
imminente de notre enfant je sentais
qu'il me fallait de vraies réponses
en fait mon idée c'est de tester un
régime à haute teneur en sucre vous
allez devoir gérer environ 40 cuillère à
café de sucre par jour 40 par jean mais
ce doit être du sucre cachés dans des
aliments et des boissons considéré comme
ça donc pas de soda pas de chocolat et
de confiserie ni de glace les habitants
de notre planète deviennent chaque jour
un peu plus mal à l'aise et beaucoup de
scientifiques estiment aujourd'hui que
le fructose en est en grande partie
riche pour ça ses influences mon cerveau
on en est sûr maintenant et je me sens
pas rassasié l'industrie sucrière a mis
en avant l'idée que toutes les calories
se valent entre elles alors qu'en
réalité elles n'ont pas le même impact
sur l'organisme et n'ont jamais eu le
même rôle à est-ce que je franchirai le
seuil de l'obésité absolument n'être
plus très loin
tous les sucres le sucre brun le sucre
blanc le jus de fruits concentrés à base
de jus de fruits ont tous les mêmes
effets sur la santé oms new york
ne sont pas super bien aujourd'hui je
suis pas aussi efficace qu'avant alors
les fonctions mentales deviennent
instables
c'est le signe d'un foie qui devient
grave c'est la première fois que je vois
que ça peut se développer en deux ou
trois semaines seulement
quand vous entrez dans un supermarché
filer directement au rayon des légumes
sans faire de détour par les autres
élèves
le sucre n'est pas mauvais en soi ni la
vie est tellement plus belle quand ans
on débarrasse